[Music]
well good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight there was an unexpected
and kind of amazing moment at the White
House today Kanye West the rapper showed
up in the Oval Office and proceeded to
give what amount you to effectively a
campaign speech while sitting directly
across from the President of the United
States and while pounding on the
presidential desk you've likely already
seen pictures of what happened it's
everywhere and the scene may have
confused you you might have concluded it
was a publicity stunt staged by famous
people in order to become more famous
you may have found yourself muttering
about the debased and celebrity centered
focus of our public discourse these days
you may even have felt a little sad
knowing that the dignified country you
grew up in is gone for good you can be
forgiven for reaching those conclusions
but they're not the whole story of what
happened today
believe it or not Kanye West said some
genuinely interesting things this
afternoon things we ought to be talking
about in public but are not they'll
probably destroy his career for saying
them he'll certainly be despised by many
of us former friends but before any of
that happens let's consider what he
actually said we'll go with the most
offensive things first here they are you
know you're black you have to be
Democrat I have conversations that
basically said that welfare is the
reason why a lot of black people end up
being Democrat they say you know first
of all it's a limit to amount of jobs so
the father's lose the jobs and they say
we'll give you more money for having
more kids in your home I think it's the
bravery that helps you beat this game
all right you know they tried to scare
me to not wear this hat my old friends
but this hat it gives me it gives me
power in a way you know my dad and my
mom separated so I didn't have a lot of
male energy in my home you know I love
everyone right but the campaign I'm with
her just didn't make me know that the
guy they didn't get to see my dad all
the time like a guy that could play
catch with his son she didn't make me
feel like a guy who could play catch
with his son Wes didn't explain exactly
what he meant by that
and yet at the very same time he could
not have put it more precisely or more
poignant Lee he grew up in a party whose
policies have systematically destroyed
the American family especially in poor
neighborhoods I didn't have a lot of
male energy in my home Wes said with
obvious sadness millions of American
kids know exactly what he is talking
about the Democratic Party won't
acknowledge these kids or their loss two
party leaders fathers in the home are at
best irrelevant and worse they're an
impediment to political power married
women tend to vote Republican and they
know that when prominent Democrats
attack of the patriarchy what they're
attacking is fathers when they wage war
on toxic masculinity what they're trying
to suppress is masculinity itself
everybody knows this few are brave
enough to say it out loud
West essentially did and then he kept
going watch this so and that's a move
one of the moves that I love that
liberals tried to do the liberal will
try to control a black person through
the concept of racism because they know
that we are very proud of motional
people so when I said I like Trump to
like someone that's liberal they'll say
oh but these races you think races okay
control me stop me that's an invisible
wall you think racism can control me
it's an invisible wall the reporters
looking on it seems stunned even
betrayed and then just to rub it in Wes
went on to defend the Bill of Rights
Watch what about gun violence with all
the debate about the Second Amendment
going on the problem is illegal guns
illegal guns is the problem not not not
legal guns we have the right to bear
arms what do we make of all of this
well obviously just from watching you
can tell that Kanye West is an eccentric
guy he meanders he talks like someone
who's never had to filter his thoughts
which probably never has had to do but
much like someone
who comes to mind Wes maybe precisely
crazy enough to think for himself and
that's a valuable quality right now no
consultant advised him to say any of
that clearly nobody controls him
sometimes he doesn't control himself but
listen carefully to what he said
sprinkle throughout his ramblings are
flashes of truth real insights into the
way the world actually is rather than
the way they tell us it is nobody else
is allowed to talk this way go ahead and
try it at work you'll get fired West
doesn't care and that makes him
dangerous to a system that is based
almost entirely on piety and lying if
you're benefiting from a system like
that kanye west must be crushed here's
the math of it the Democratic
presidential candidates everyone who
runs needs to get almost the entire
black vote in order to win a national
election that's not easy to do so in
order to do it
Democrats so racial division they pit
Americans against each other based on
their ethnicity you can't support them
they're the wrong color you hear that
all the time it's now the essential
Democratic argument its destructive but
more ominously for Democrats it may no
longer be working a poll by Public
Broadcasting just last week found that
Trump's approval rating with Hispanic
voters is 41% that's higher than it is
with college-educated white voters if
anything like that ever happened among
African American voters the game would
be over so that can't happen
Kayne West must be destroyed and so the
thought police swooped in almost
immediately to arrest this disobedient
artist and declare him incompetent Wow
okay I'm doing this for everybody who's
watching us who turned their volume down
you can put it back up again but if you
think you're going to get a sawed filet
by play and political analysis you're
not because that was an assault on our
White House it was a combination of
stream of consciousness I felt like I
was sitting in on a psychiatric visit
and a commercial for Donald Trump what I
saw was a minstrel show today him in
front of all of these white people
mostly white people embarrassing himself
and embarrassing Americans but mostly
African Americans yeah shut up Kanye
you're
crazy keep in mind this is coming from
the same people who believe Hillary
Clinton is entirely well indeed a
serious person they're hoping this works
this crazy stuff and that you believe
them and just in case you don't they
want to remind you that Kanye West is a
race traitor as Don Lemon just said who
has a low IQ here was CNN on Tuesday
night
Kanye West is what happens when Negroes
don't read and and we have this now and
now Donald Trump is going to use it and
pervert it and he's gonna have somebody
who can stand with him and take pictures
Kanye because he's put on a Magda hat
and he's an attention [ __ ] like the
president he's all of a sudden now the
the model spokesperson he's he's the
token negro of the of the Trump
administration got that he can't read
because he's the n-word that's what the
liberals on a liberal cable channel are
now telling you but they have no choice
they are terrified you will listen to a
Kanye West is saying and that's not
allowed